picture this you post a video on YouTube
and because of YouTube's powerful
algorithms and the fact that it's the
second largest search engine in the
world that video gets views 24/7 365 for
not just weeks months but possibly for
years
now if you've connected that one video
that you posted on YouTube to a way of
making money in this case with affiliate
marketing then you are truly making
money while you sleep this is not a pipe
dream this in fact is a very practical
strategy that we've helped hundreds of
people implement to create passive
income and truly earn money why they
sleep and in this video and podcast
you're gonna be learning five specific
tips for how you can make money while
you sleep with affiliate marketing so
buckle your seatbelt and stick around
because this is the think Marketing Pat
podcast here we go podcast the number
one podcast for growing and scaling your
business with online video
I'm your host Heather Torres and I'm
Sean kennel and we are from think media
and if this is your first time listening
we appreciate you being here and want to
say thank you
this show is dedicated to helping you
get your content notice and the latest
money-making strategies that are working
right now online so whether you want to
grow a YouTube channel or you want to
maximize video across all of social
media this is for you in this episode
we're gonna be talking about how to make
money while you sleep with affiliate
marketing and five specific tips that
you can implement today but listen this
is actually part two of an essential
two-part series and you don't want to
miss part one so if you're just
listening to this episode or watching
the video podcast right now then make
sure to go back and check out part one
in the podcast history in the Spotify
history in the YouTube video library but
in part two we're gonna go a little bit
deeper and talk about really some
advanced strategies like some things
that you'll layer on once you've gotten
started with affiliate marketing once
you've got some things
set up these are some tips that will
help you come up with the right content
that will bring in the right viewers and
that will generate more sales so that'll
make you more money and five tips that
I've learned over now generating over a
million dollars in affiliate marketing
of profit probably over ten million
dollars in terms of top-line affiliate
sales because again you get a percentage
of it and so I've learned a lot made a
lot of mistakes over the years and I've
had a lot of success as well and so
you're gonna love this episode now this
episode is brought to you by grow with
video live that is our annual conference
and this year it is a virtual experience
that is gonna be amazing you can learn
more details and grow with video
live.com and where this content is
actually from is from a session that I
did at my friend chalene johnson's event
called the marketing impact Academy
we're jumping into part two with the
second five of 10 tips and she's one of
our growth video live speakers this year
she's one of the most intelligent serial
entrepreneurs her husband Brett Johnson
had built multiple seven-figure
businesses they've sold businesses they
are super intelligent and social media
she's been featured in HuffPost and
entrepreneur in different publications
as one of the top female entrepreneurs
to follow and she's just one of our
speakers if you want to see all of our
speakers go to growth video live.com
we've got an incredible lineup this year
and what's the point of the conference
it's gonna help you grow with video it's
gonna help you grow your business with
video grow your church with video grow
your side hustle with video grow your
brand with video and master video and
live-streaming so that you can get your
message out into the world and not just
make high income but also make high
impact with whatever it is you want to
do we'll talk about that a little bit
more later in on the podcast but for now
buckle your seat belt and get ready for
the featured content today affiliate
marketing changed my life affiliate
marketing is a cool way to earn a
commission when you recommend products
that you love and use and it's amazing
because you're really just serving
people
I mean affiliate marketing does not make
the product cost more it is simply
allowing you to recommend something and
share something and get a piece of that
action so it should be a win-win-win
affiliate marketing is when you talk
about a product like I'll talk about a
camera and think about who wins
hopefully Canon wins because they sold a
camera hopefully the person who got the
camera wins because now they have a tool
for creating content that they love and
get to use and then we win at think
media or I win because I made a little
bit of a commission off that and when I
do it at scale I'm able to build a life
on my own terms and make money while I
sleep that's our goal here at the thick
marketing podcasts we don't think other
people have to lose in order for us to
win we believe that the world is an
abundant place and so when you do
affiliate marketing right it is a win
win win win win and so come on all we do
is win we're gonna jump into these next
five tips buckle your seat belt get
ready and here we go it's number six
higher ticket higher Commission's higher
ticket higher Commission's so maybe you
do beauty and lifestyle or or makeup and
maybe it's even like if it was like
drugstore makeup it's more affordable
and there's a lot of youtubers that do
stuff like that even if you do
high-volume you might not be able to
make that much money because you're
selling like a seven dollar lipstick and
you're making like four percent so it's
only a matter of cents now if you do
scale you can do it but this is why if
the price of the item is higher you
could potentially do higher make a lot
more revenue so ask yourself what is the
affiliate marketing commission
percentage amazon's four to ten percent
there's a lot of programs that will do
twenty percent thirty percent sometimes
you get fifty you can even get like
eighty percent like it varies and then
also ask how much does the product cost
because for doing affiliate marketing at
scale if you're selling more expensive
stuff that's how you can make higher
revenues so this is Timothy's a part of
some of our advanced training and so
he's talking about drones this is the DJ
I affiliate program not even Amazon and
this is really old screenshot but
fifteen thousand five hundred and sixty
two dollars from the DJI affiliate
program by putting out some content out
there but these drones cost like a
thousand dollars each at least and so
even at ten percent it's a hundred
dollar Commission if you make
a sale right so higher ticket higher
Commission's sometimes I'll do things
and I'll bring up this case study later
but a lot of times in the health
industry this is some green juice that I
like to drink is called organifi like
the commission on that is 30%
and it's also continuity of someone to
subscribes to it every month whereas on
Amazon I'm only getting four to ten
percent higher percentage higher
commissions a friend of mine Pat Flynn
who's spoken here who knows Pat Flynn
amazing guy smart passive income so he's
doing a lot of things in his business
affiliate marketing is just one like
bolt-on part of his business he's got
events and he's got courses but he's a
big promoter of convertkit and he's
generated thousands of dollars a month
on really reoccurring because of helping
people with not just continuity when
they subscribe to it but it's a little
bit higher ticket because people are
subscribing to a software-as-a-service
in that particular case number seven
this is if this is relevant if you've
got a blog it's relevant on YouTube it's
relevant anywhere it's Pinterest as well
it's where they're searched where there
could be SEO search engine optimization
tip number seven is solved searched
problems solve search problems do you
drink coffee any coffee lovers in the
room there's no way it's only like ten
people
everybody else was like I do look like I
do but I haven't had any enough recently
so I can't read I can't react
oh you can't that's funny and so this is
just an example again back on those
experiments and I'm sharing these
because remember I want you to stay on
brand but these are these are just cool
ways and things I've done in my life and
my business so as I going through life
I'm always paying attention I learned
about this affiliate marketing stuff I
learned that YouTube is a search engine
and I was like going through life till
one day somebody gifted me a Starbucks
grease mill and this cool machine kind
of makes coffee an espresso for you but
you have to buy coffee pods for it from
Starbucks and they're a premium priced
so one day I was over at my friend
Rachel's house and she had the exact
same machine as made she pulled out this
drawer and she had this variety of
coffee from somewhere else that just fit
perfectly in that machine it was from
Coffee Bean Tea Leaf I was like what is
this mysterious coffee or introducing me
to and she's like yes see BTL pods very
affordable more variety of coffee and
yes they fit perfectly in this Starbucks
machine and they work so I thought hmm I
drink I drank my coffee and ideas began
to flow I went home and sure enough
people were looking Ducey BTL pods work
in a Starbucks barista mo so just like
the Christmas lights I was like well I
will answer that question on the
internet so I just shot a video and I in
the very video I was like hey maybe
you're wondering do these pods work yes
and there's links in the description
below to them the video is more helpful
than that but you know we tasted some of
whatever but sure enough there's there's
an affiliate link in the description so
I talked about I answer the question I
solve a problem I introduce somebody to
an answer they're looking for
information and then there's a link in
the description so now literally I so
coffee every single day if not every
single week and that's another chance
for someone to click the link for it to
be tracked for anything else they buy
are you seeing how cool this is cool and
so power question and and key here add
value and be helpful I mean I sell it to
make goal in this like if you just meet
somebody and you solve a question and
then you're like it's way more about the
you and way less about selling I know
none of us want to sell or like selling
and that's not what it's about it's
about adding value and being helpful and
so I just do that in the video so that's
the question
power question what are the problems and
questions your target audience is
currently trying to solve make videos
around those blog posts around those
podcasts around that with some show
notes and and then connect that to
affiliate marketing income streams
alright tip number eight more content
more money mo money mo prompts I mean
whatever and so and so what I began to
do once I figured out something that was
working and I did that gift ideas video
years ago I got a little weird on it and
I just started making all kinds of gift
ideas videos this before I what I did
today
but then I was like all right gift ideas
for Mother's Day Valentine's Day men
versus him there's my wife's gift ideas
for women you know now I'm like honey
shoot a video and Christmas gift ideas
tech gift ideas gift ideas for creative
people it started like digging deep
getting weird with it
but what I learned right it's just that
again once you start seeing all you got
to do is make one dollar online you go
oh I could do more of this I can repeat
this process I could I could dial it in
and of course I'm getting better on
camera as I go out I'm still learning
I'm you know I'm still growing and so
more content more money and a power
question here is how can you increase
the quality but also the quantity of
your content and I love this in the
context of m.i.a because I've been
reflecting with you as I've been taking
notes and sitting here and learning
about how to how to simplify and and we
need to be doing less and I think this
can align with that what I'm just saying
is how can you there's not that you
necessarily have to work harder but how
can you work smarter to just level up
the quality of your content and
potentially think quantity one of my
favorite things is called batch
production where whenever I whenever I
shoot a video
I never shoot one I like to shoot two to
four to eight all in one sitting and
then if you only release one a week but
shoot for videos when you turn the
camera on now you've got a month's worth
of content all shot at once and so how
can you increase the quality and the
quantity of your content tip number nine
is audience intense audience intent in
the context of YouTube I would and this
is that keywords everywhere to lie so
that's how cool it is it'll show you
right there when you just type in like a
search the search volume per month so I
typed in best vegan in the youtube
search bar the first recommendation
there is best vegan protein powder
18,000 people a month are asking that
question across the internet that's
Google that's a Google number but it's
relevant across the different places and
so what is the intent of the person that
of the 18 thousand 100 people every
single month that is looking for that
thing they want some protein powder like
psycho psychologically they are like
sitting down and being like what is the
best protein powder I have a feeling
they have their credit card ready
they're looking for an answer and they
want to buy some protein powder the goal
would probably be by the end of the day
to discover the best vegan protein
powder and make a purchase right so
audience intent this is very important
for generating income online because now
you're standing in front of someone
who's basically ready to buy right vs.
on first glance funny cat now the first
recommendation here funny cat videos has
one hundred and sixty-five thousand
searches a month
well of course on a surface level that's
that's much more it's so many more than
the people looking for vegan protein
powder but what is their intent they're
not in a buying mode they're not looking
they don't have their credit card out
there in an entertainment mode they're
they're looking for entertainment which
is what you'd want to deliver you'd want
to deliver a funny cat video and he says
so you go in like Rachel's funny cat
page even though she hasn't known any
cats and but you have that funny cat
video there and but it's the wrong
intent
so it'd be hard to monetize off of that
well that's what
cool when you put out content right in
front of someone who's like basically
ready to buy ready to make a purchase
and so I've always thought about this I
think somebody someday maybe this exists
should start a luxury watch YouTube
channel because if you type in it's
crazy
you can type in Breitling NAV timer
versus Omega Speedmaster
70 people a month search for that but
what are those 70 people probably about
to do they're trying to decide between
those two watches and even if you link
to those on Amazon those suckers cost
like three four or five thousand dollars
each and so your commission on that is
going to be multiple hundreds of dollars
and you throw some content out into the
world and just people are getting good
education from because you know what
you're talking about in this arena or
whatever it is and and then BOOM you're
in front of the right audience intent
are you getting value out of this so far
so ask yourself what is the intent of
the viewer what is the intent of the
person that's coming to me looking for
help looking for whatever it is and then
position your content to serve to add
value to help and then you can monetize
that a huge level through affiliate
marketing alright we're gonna get to
point number ten in just a second but I
wanted to pass the question off to you
and ask have you generated your first
sale with affiliate marketing yet also
do you have any questions about
affiliate marketing I'd love to help so
let me know in the youtube comments
below now when it comes to affiliate
marketing all these strategies are real
and these are the very strategies that
I'm using even this year but there's one
big missing piece for making affiliate
marketing work and that is if you're not
getting traffic yet like if you're not
getting views if you don't have like
that you know momentum on your channel
so if you ultimately want to learn like
how to get more views on your videos I
put together a free checklist you can go
to tube checklist com I'll link to that
in the description below
and that goes through things like
titling your videos how to like
structure your video content I actually
put together a free video series as well
so the secret kind of to making all this
work was generating massive influence
and massive views on YouTube if you want
to learn how to do that check out tube
checklist com and let's check out point
number 10 right now now tip number 10 is
increased traffic increase
traffic remember traffic means views how
many page views you're getting how many
views your videos are getting a month
how much traffic your you your facebook
page is getting whatever it is and so
one of the biggest problems once you
have some of these pieces in place you
might get your favorite things site in
place I hope you do on your website
where you just list off the stuff you're
using your favorite stuff once you have
this stuff in place then your goal is
just okay how can I send more traffic
here right and so here's my favorite
strategy and just as one example but ask
for yourself how can I just get more
traffic on whatever your favorite
platform so YouTube is the second
largest search engine in the world
Google is the first and Google owns
YouTube so people go to YouTube looking
for answers right so you remember this
channel is where I talk about lifestyle
stuff and so I mentioned that protein
powder or greens powder I should say so
it's green juice but it's empowered form
you mix it with water so in my research
I found this term best greens powder
like best greens about people were
looking for this thousands a month in
fact and so I created a video around it
this is called ranking videos and so
you're ranking a video in search you're
figuring out what someone's looking for
like what their intent is where their
search volume and then you're designing
a piece of content to answer that
inquiry so I made a video best greens
powder question mark organic green juice
review and here's what's cool about
doing this is this one video now is over
a thousand days old but it's generated
574 new subscribers I only made it once
over a thousand days ago but it just
continues to grow you could see that
blue line of growth it's got over a
hundred and six thousand views and that
blue line means it just keeps getting
views what I love about YouTube is it's
kind of like real estate it like if you
put out good content it can grow in
value over time and people keep watching
it over time even though you just did it
once this video gets 386 views every two
days that crazy and so this is my
favorites this is a YouTube strategy but
basically putting your content in front
of these terms so here's this case study
it's over a thousand days old it's
building my
on autopilot when your content is on
brand and people are looking they don't
know about you yet but they know they
want to find some vegan protein powder
then two things happen at once they
don't know you but they're typing that
end they find you they hear your promise
in your tag line that you're designing
here at Mi a and they go oh cool I'm not
only looking for this I'm also going to
subscribe to you not everybody but
here's the case study it's building my
brand building more followers it's
generated over $1000 from YouTube ads I
do have YouTube ads turned on that's not
that impressive but that is cool like
over a couple years a thousand dollars
but what's even cooler is that it
generates two to three hundred dollars a
month from affiliate marketing about
three grand a year one video that was
made over a thousand days ago what would
happen if you started adding videos like
that to your brand of your business
would that be good yes it would
affiliate marketing is so powerful and I
hope that those tips inspired you with
some fresh ideas and remember there's a
part one to this so if you actually
haven't even started with affiliate
marketing yet make sure to go back in
the podcast or the YouTube channel and
listen to part one but listen one of the
biggest challenges with affiliate
marketing is if you haven't built your
influence first then income won't come
second like if nobody's watching your
videos or you don't have any viewers and
you don't have anybody on your email
list or no one's listening your podcast
your first challenge is to get views aka
traffic actually to get that awareness
influence comes first income comes
second and so if you really want to
scale your income with affiliate
marketing you got to get more traffic
and learn how to get more traffic and
one of the best ways to do that is to
join us at grow with video live yes our
event this episode's brought to you by
growth video live our annual event here
at think media and you can learn more
about it at growth video live.com what
it is is our annual conference that's
gonna help you grow with video and
obviously we're gonna talk a lot about
YouTube and YouTube's a huge passion of
ours and I believe a pillar and a staple
that it's irresponsible for you not to
be on YouTube no matter who you are it
is the Town Square of video influence in
my opinion
but there is so much opportunity my
friends to be doing video IG TV
Instagram stories stories are everywhere
YouTube's got stories LinkedIn's working
on stories of course Facebook Scott's
stories Facebook Scott video Facebook
live video LinkedIn Scott video LinkedIn
live video tik-tok his video and all of
those various video platforms we're
gonna be educating you of course I don't
think you can focus on all of them all
at once not even we do with the team
that we have at think media but we're
gonna help you put together your video
success plan for what you should be
doing with video at grow with video live
we're bringing in the best speakers and
the best experts and their respective
platforms we got chalene johnson she'll
be talking about Instagram we got Jayde
talking all about tik-tok we got
Michaela Alexis Dharma Wong
by the way Jade our Mwanza we got of
course YouTube experts like roberto
blake and so many great people plus
people talking about how to become a
better communicator video podcasting my
friend pat flynn so check out growth
video live.com you can reserve your
tickets starting at just $97 and all the
details are at grow with video live.com
the three big focuses of the conference
or this strategy psychology and
community you know I think we have so
much respect and love for a lot of the
people in our industry but we feel that
we've been given kind of a special focus
on those three things in our business
and here's what I mean I really believe
that success on YouTube in online
business is about strategy psychology
and community and a lot of people just
focus on strategy what are the tactics
what are the two do's what are the tips
what are the mechanics of how this stuff
works which is critical by the way you
got the wrong tips wrong tactics wrong
strategy you're not gonna win but I
really believe that strategy is probably
only about 20% of success I think that
another 40% of success is probably
psychology what's that the mindset
beliefs and the inner game that actually
causes you to take action come on if
you're like me you've probably read
books taking courses watch videos and
you have information but you haven't put
it into action
that's psychology that's the mindset
that's the belief system and it grows
video alive we deal with your BS
come on your belief system what do you
think I meant
we are gonna deal with your psychology
as well so that you have the confidence
the inner game the mindset for success
with social media and online video but
look I think another 40 percent of
success is community that show me your
friends and I'll show you your future
you are an average of the 5 people that
you're closest to who you're surrounded
by you know and if you're around toxic
doubters kritis Escritt a-- scisors
haters and i'm not just talking about
your mom and your wife just kidding i'm
kidding it's a joke but you know maybe
not you know i'm not saying don't like
hang out with your your grumpy friend i
am saying when you get around other
like-minded ambitious creative
purpose-driven entrepreneurs that are
building things that are better that
what all maybe your circle currently
thinks is impossible they just go of
course it's possible your possible it's
possible because look at all the people
that are doing it you get around a
different environment where all things
become possible that's your community
and success really rubs off on from
those who are around you you know in so
many different areas when in fact when I
Scott around my friend chalene johnson I
first started listening to her podcast
she's one of our growth video live
speakers and this session I just shared
was at her event man when I first got
around her I was listening to her
podcast first part of her Academy next
and that changed my life because it was
changing my thinking it was changing my
belief system my mindset and I was
taking action and I was learning all
kinds of stuff but then I actually
worked for her in team Johnson and I did
videography work for them and they hired
me to do some video testimonials and
shoot one of their conferences and so
now I was around them more than I was
around their team but here's also what
happened was at that time I was sitting
around a lot editing a lot of video I
was not active I was not super healthy
and a lot of my physical my physical
body my eating decisions and different
things like that and she's a fitness
celebrity she wrote you know she has the
131 diet went through one method
she's best-selling New York Times
bestselling author I mean if you haven't
heard of Celine
since she invented piyo and turbo Jam
and turbo turbo kick so like I actually
now fast forward to today I went on a
snowboard trip with them a couple times
and no they they freaking work out
before they go snowboarding I'm like I'm
not working out before I go I'm going
snowboarding like I'm not gonna go do
legs before I go do legs on the mountain
but she works out like seven days a week
and not because it's like some weird
thing it's because it's part of her
lifestyle it's part of like just her
mindset and I realized men there's the
time for that they have the energy for
that man her and her family their kids
they have an incredible just team
incredible culture but guess what
happened it rubbed off on me and I saw a
transformation of my health which is not
the purpose of this podcast I'm just
talking about the power of community I
saw a transformation in my health
because of who I was around you know if
you are hanging out with five people
that are overweight guess what you'll
probably be the six if you're hanging
out with five people who just think that
cheating on your spouse and like
marriage doesn't really matter and you
know let's just jump into the next let's
just do whatever and like let's just get
you know whatever divorces and look I
know we go through things there's no
judgment here but if you've been around
five people who just are going from
divorce to divorce you'll probably be
the six if you're hanging out with five
alcoholics you'll probably be the six
and if you're hanging out with five
people who are crushing their excuses
building their influence on YouTube and
building their online businesses and
overcoming every obstacle guess what
you'll probably be the sixth that was a
long diatribe on the power of community
and that's what we want to create here
not just that think media and think
marketing but that's the power of growth
in your life and we are doing some
incredibly innovative things this year
in terms of creating community even
though it's a virtual event we have
interactive community building
activities high-powered sessions and
you're also gonna leave with clarity
you're gonna leave with an action plan
for your next steps for growing your
brand and business with video so I hope
you could join us at growth video
live.com from anywhere in the world you
can be in your living room your office
your home office your car your houseboat
your tree house if you got internet and
power up there
you know your treehouse alright that's
that's that's what happens on the think
marketing podcast but check it out grow
with video live.com is where all the
information is about that that brings us
to our iTunes Apple podcast review of
the day and today's review comes from
tallest Robbie or Robi always the
highlight of my day I've been listening
to this podcast from the beginning thank
you so much thank you for being a part
of the community listening to every
episode every episode and I mean all of
them always helps me thank you for being
so diehard in a part of the community
much love I have never left the podcast
feeling like I wasted my time I can't
stress how big of a deal that is you
won't be sorry you listen to this
podcast thank you so much for being a
part of our community tallest robbie and
appreciates you so much it would mean
the world to me if you've been get value
out of the think marketing podcast
myself Heather to think maybe a team if
you could go to Apple podcasts and leave
and rate and review the podcast this is
a great way of spreading the word and no
matter if you're watching this on
YouTube or somewhere else
hit the like button drop a comment below
answering the question of the day and
that is what is your next steps with
affiliate marketing you know we learned
five tips I hope you've watched part one
how you gonna put this into action how
are you gonna apply affiliate marketing
to start earning your main source of
revenue online or an extra source of
revenue online let me know your aha
moment from today's episode if you're in
the youtube comments if you're watching
somewhere else you're just listening on
Spotify or Apple or Google then write it
down write it in your own notes tweet me
at Sean kennel rhymes with YouTube
channel s EAN last names C a and and e
ll and let me know what you got out of
today's pick marketing podcasts cuz as
we land the plane I want to remind you
that we are action takers here at the
think brand we are action takers hashtag
action takers and that means that we're
not just here to get some information
and we strive to bring you value every
time so you
don't waste your time when you listen to
this podcast but here's the deal
information is not enough if it's just
head knowledge but it doesn't get
implemented into our lives then we'll
never get the results and listen we are
obsessed with your outcomes we want to
help 10,000 Purpose Driven entrepreneurs
create a full-time living doing what
they love while making a difference in
the world with YouTube in online video
and then help them sustain that success
without losing their soul because even
on our mission we've noticed that a lot
of times success can be come with a lot
of dangers to it as well I heard one
person say it's hard to deal with
failure but try dealing with success
success can room sometimes more lives
than even failure can but it's not gonna
ruin your life because we actually
believe that you can be successful and
also not lose your soul in the process
and so that's our mission here we are
obsessed with your success with you
getting results you being able to reach
your goals with YouTube with online
business reach financial autonomy
bolt-on extra income streams to your
business but why do I say all that
because if you don't take action then
you're not gonna get the results so what
do you need to do next
yes what do you need to do with
affiliate marketing but what you might
need to do next is actually stopped
listening to think marketing podcasts
for a while and go post some videos
we'll be here when you come back we'll
be here we're here every week come on
we're not gonna miss this we're here for
you
but at some point you got to be putting
action out there and when you are
learning and then doing and then
learning and then doing that is where
you learn the most we learn by doing and
so we need the tactics and the
information then we go apply it and then
we go oh we did it kind of wrong made a
lot of mistakes but at least we started
Messi punch fair in the face press
record got the video out there and I can
always get 1% better on the next one
learn and do learn and do so what action
do you need to take next can you put
that on your calendar
can you calendar block when you're gonna
put that into action shoot that next
video record that live stream send that
email reach out to that person you want
to collab with come on sign up for that
affiliate program
come on learn that finish that course
that you're working on finish that
module take those notes
register for growth in your life I don't
know the next action you need to take is
but we are action takers in this
community and I believe this is the most
powerful community on the internet and
that we really are part of something
special in a movement because we are
we've seen like almost a hundred people
now hit that full-time target of and
that's like from scratch we had a lot of
people in our community that already had
liked it they were already like running
their own business like my friend Nick
from greyscale guerrilla we actually met
an event he joined VRA we became friends
after he had been through kind of the
program and been a part of the community
he always already had a successful
business he bolted on like tens of
thousands or a couple extra hundred
thousands of dollars of revenue to his
business so the way that looks is so
different for so many people in our
community but I'm talking people that
like started at zero like Mary from
Mary's nest who got her silver play
button and is that like one hundred
forty thousand subscribers now she
started zero when she first got
connected to our community it's crazy
the results people are getting I believe
that can happen for you and so many for
us in this community but not if we don't
take action longest outro of my life I
don't even know why I'm why you're still
here and I'm still here this is not
podcast best practice but we need to be
taking action
write it down write that next thing down
write that thing down that's you've been
procrastinating and turn off the podcast
and go press record hey I appreciate you
so much so grateful that's you're a part
of this community and that we're
connected and I can't wait to see in the
next episode of the think marketing
podcast until then keep crushing it keep
smashing it and we will talk soon peace